hello in this video we'll talk about
plant tissue culture system
and we would understand the basics of
plant tissue culture and its application
so plant tissue culture is a method by
which plant cells can be cultured
artificially in order to grow plants
or plant organs so this is an overview
before we move on to plant tissue
culture technique we should understand
three fundamental abilities of a plant
cell
which makes it possible to culture in
vitro
first capability is known as toti
potency
toti potency simply means the potential
of
a plant cell to give rise to an entire
plant
and this is kind of like a totipotent
stem cell
which can give rise to a entire organism
so any cell from plant
can be cultured and can be
ultimately induced to form
a mature plant link second capability is
known as differentiation and
redifferentiation
differentiation simply means specific
lineage commitment so once a plant cell
is committed to a particular
tissue type or cell type that is known
as
differentiation and these differentiated
tissues
can be differentiated that means
once once specification is done the
specification can be reversed
and it can get back to a
undifferentiated mass
which can be further redifferentiated to
a completely different
substance so this phenomena of
differentiation d differentiation and
redifferentiation makes it possible
to culture plants and several aspect of
tissue culture is possible due to this
phenomenon and third
option is competency which simply means
the endogenous potential of a given cell
or tissue to develop to a particular way
so it's kind of like a genetic program
which is inbuilt and which is helping or
guiding the
cells to grow into a particular fate
so these three factors are absolutely
essential for plant tissue culture
let us talk about the advantage and
disadvantage of plant tissue culture in
a moment
so first of all the new plant lids
can be grown in a very short amount of
time so you can bypass
the long time to produce a plant in a
field
only small amount of plant material is
required a small portion of the leaf or
a small portion of the meristem
is more than sufficient to grow a entire
plant so that's the biggest advantage of
this technique
new plantlets or plants are more likely
to be free of viruses
or any kind of diseases and this is
really important for
production of virus free or
pathogen-free plants
the process is not dependent upon any
season right
so you can enjoy let's say orange even
in scorching
summer so this is the biggest advantage
from an economic point of view and
people who are looking to cultivate
challenging plants which are not
grown in a particular region if they
want to grow them
the soil conditions or the atmospheric
conditions might not be favorable for
that
so a laboratory setup or a in vitro
situation might be
advantageous for that fact right but
there are certain disadvantages
associated with this tissue culture
system
first tissue culture can require
high labor and it could be very costly
at least the initial setup
for many of the agriculture dependent
countries which are third world
countries it is
absolutely difficult to invest so much
of money on the initial setup
now there could be chance of plants to
be
uh less comfortable with the
environmental conditions because
because they are growing in a sterile
environment and they're
less resistant to diseases or less
resistance to environmental changes so
there could be a big question mark
whether these kind of plant tissue
culture techniques
can be appropriate for every
environmental situation
and lastly there could be failure of
growing
growth of plants there could be aberrant
effects in the plant tissue cultures
which leads to
disease plant or imperfect growth so
these are all the disadvantages that one
should consider
while thinking of performing a tissue
culture experiment
now let's talk about the factors that
affect plant tissue culture
first of all the growth media because we
are growing the plants
in vitro so that is why we have to
ensure that proper minerals growth
factors carbon sources
and hormones are present in this growth
media which can support the plant growth
after that temperature humidity sunlight
all of these conditions has to be met
for
a proper plant growth and that need to
be provided artificially
genetic factors are always present for a
proper growth of plant
from a tissue culture setup lastly the
explant source the starting material we
are using
for growing a plant obviously a tissue
which is less differentiated
has a greater chance or it would be best
for making a new plant
compared to a tissue which is totally
differentiated
now let's talk about the basic
components of the plant
culture media it should have all the
essential
elements the macro and the
micronutrients that are important for
plant growth
it should have plant hormones such as
auxin and cytokinin
and other hormones which really helps in
plant growth
it should have a carbon source generally
the carbon source
is actually sucrose and ultimately it
should have a supply of
organic elements such as vitamins
and amino acids which are important for
anabolic responses in a plant
so at least these four group of factors
are
essential for a plant to grow in a
tissue culture setting now let's talk
about the tissue culture
types so at least there are these six
tissue culture types
including whole embryo culture
seedling culture organ culture callous
culture suspension culture
and protoplast culture so each of these
culture methodologies has their own
advantage and disadvantages and they can
be utilized in particular purposes
so in subsequent time we would look at
these particular applications
first let's start with callous culture
so callus formation in
plant can be induced in several ways
callus simply means a growing mass which
is unorganized
and undifferentiated and these are
basically parenchyma cells
now plant callus can be
derived from somatic tissues
callus formation is induced from a plant
tissue sample after surface
sterilization
and it is important because callus
can be infected by other pathogens or it
can be contaminated
so that is why maintaining a sterile
environment while performing a callous
culture
is absolutely essential the cells that
give rise to callus
or somatic embryos usually undergo
rapid division or partially
undifferentiated such as
they could be also partially undifferent
undifferentiated such as meristem
tissues now there could be
the x-plant source and while choosing
the explant source we have to ensure
that we are choosing a good explant
source that can give rise to a plant for
example if we
compare between a leaf explant and a
meristem explant a meristem explain
would be far better
option for growing a callus now placing
that
explant into a particular medium such as
ms medium or murashiges cook medium
is the first step of callus formation
after putting it into the medium and
waiting for several days the callus
would be formed and it looks like these
tumor-like tissues which are kind of
undifferentiated it doesn't have any
shape or size and
when it comes when it is
taken into account from a molecular
point of view they are
undifferentiated their lineages are not
committed
so these callous would be eventually
maturing
into a particular somatic plantlet and
that can be
placed into a soil or they can be grown
artificially
so from these callus a entire plant lid
can be formed
so callous growth has at least three
phases first of all the induction phase
second the rapid division and the growth
phase more
like more or less this is like a log
phase and then ultimately there would be
a declining phase where the callus
is not anymore growing and there could
be infection in the calories and
due to the scarcity of media and
nutrients
so plant hormones are used to induce
or initiate the callus formation so let
us look at the factors that induce
callus formation
few factors which are essential for
callous formation is
auxin and cytokinin the relative balance
of oxygen and cytokinin determines
few factors in terms of plant growth if
oxygen is high
cytokinin is low then root development
is
augmented if cytokinin is high oxygen is
low
should development is preferred but if
auxin
cytokinin are in a equivalent one is to
one ratio
then callus development is induced
let us talk about the advantages and
disadvantages of this callus culture
the advantage includes making transgenic
crop
reviving infected crop that we have
learned from many stem cultures
and plant biomedical researches
ultimately disadvantage includes the
initial
cost and requirement of expensive
culture media
and there could be chances then the
propagated plant will be less resilient
towards diseases and environmental
changes so these are the
disadvantage of callous culture a
modification of callous culture is cell
suspension culture
when callus pieces are agitated in a
liquid medium
they first dissociate and then
reassociate in that
particular agitation settings and this
is better for nutrient supply continuous
agitation make sure the
nutrient is reaching even in the deep
layer of the catalyst
but while in a stationary condition in a
solid medium this nutrient might not
reach into the inner part of the callus
and that might lead to the
death of the callus in a mature state
and this happens a lot
while culturing callus so again we start
with the explant source
we induce a callous growth and once
callus has grown
to a particular stage we would take the
callus
and put it in a start tank reactor where
the callus would be starved
and the nutrients can reach deep inside
the callus and this is
known as cell suspension culture cell
suspension culture has
a lot of usage let me introduce you to
the usage of that
so cell suspension culture is
used widely to produce secondary
metabolites of plants
secondary metabolite of plants might
have medical in
importance so there are two type of
metabolites in plants primary metabolism
which is respiration photosynthesis and
other biochemical pathways
and secondary metabolism involves
phenolics
biosynthesis alkaloid biosynthesis or
flavinoid biosynthesis etc
so these compounds phenol phenolics
alkaloids and flavinoids
they might have medical importance or
relevant for human benefit
for example placid axle which is derived
from a particular plant
has anti-cancerous property whereas
digoxy
digoxin is used for
cardiac treatment or treatment of
cardiac arrhythmia
diastonin which mimics a steroid-like
molecule
is important for birth control
peels so it has an anti-fertility effect
so we understand that secondary
metabolites can be grown with
kalos with suspension cultures and its
usage in terms of human benefits
now come to protoplast culture
protoblast can be generated by stripping
of the cell wall of the plant cell
so what is protoplast protoplast is
simply
a plant cell which is devoid of its cell
wall
and there are certain benefits of
protoplast culture let me
tell you that so protoblast are widely
used
for genetic manipulation in plants
because incorporating a genomic dna
or a plasmid dna into a plant cell is
very difficult due to the cell wall
once the cell wall is removed it is kind
of
easy to get the dna of your choice
inside this plant cell
so plot protoplast preparations are
actually
used by plant scientists for genetic
manipulation
other than that there are many
techniques known as protoplast fusion
which are used to overcome species
barrier for example
a species of tomato and a potato are
different
so they cannot be
they cannot reproduce with each other
right because there is a species barrier
and that can be overcome with protoplast
fusion
so protoplast from one plant is prepared
and another plant is prepared and then
they can be fused with polyethylene
glycol treatment
that leads to these fused cell types
and this is called as somatic hybrid
one kind of application is cybrids
cyborg stands for cycloplasmic hybrids
where two cells are taken and one cell
is generally
enucleated and then
they are fused together so the nucleus
or the genetic material is completely
coming from the other cell
whereas the cytoplasmic components are
mixed up between these two cells
ultimately
they can give rise to siblings and these
are known as cybrid variants
and cybrid cybilization technique is
used
for plant advancement or plant tissue
culture advancements
so let me talk about the advantages of
this technique first of all it can
overcome
sexual incompatibility barrier between
two different species
and it can be used to study cytoplasmic
or mitochondrial genes
and their inheritance and their
importance in terms of plant growth and
other aspects
let's talk about the embryo culture the
embryo of different developmental stages
formed within the female gametophyte via
sexual process
can be isolated and cultured as a whole
under aseptic condition and this is
known as the embryo culture
there are certain advantages of embryo
culture
such as such as like overcoming the
embryo abortion due to incompatibility
barriers
overcoming seed dormancy or
self-stability of seeds
shortening of the breeding cycle all of
these are advantages of
embryo culture so we pretty much looked
at several plant tissue culture
techniques
lastly we would talk about hydroponics
hydroponics is a method by which plants
can be
grown in a soil free situation where
the necessary minerals and
ions macro and micro molecules which are
essential for plant growth
is provided in a liquid media here you
can see the media is circulating
so the media is not stagnant and there
are high probability that the root would
get
enough amount of media at every stage
and
these plants are cultivated under
artificial light situation which is
essential for their
photosynthesis purposes so this can
lead to vertical farming or growing
plants in artificial settings under
greenhouses
and that that has a lot of implication
in terms of agriculture
because for example we can enjoy the
flavor of oranges for the whole
year by these kind of artificial
techniques so organic farming and
vertical farming is really blooming
these days due to these kind of advances
in the plant tissue culture and that is
the motivation of studying plant tissue
culture
from a cellular and molecular point of
view so i hope you enjoyed this video if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe and if you like my videos
please subscribe to my patreon channel
and your support is absolutely essential
for my channel growth
so feel free to support me in patreon
you can also take my unacademic courses
which is india's biggest learning
platform
using my code ap 10 you can get a 10
discount
off on all my courses thanks for
listening and do let me know your
feedback in the comment section thank
you guys